you
you guys are ready to wait with them
good evening everyone and welcome to
book people thank you so much for coming
out here tonight we love putting on
events such as this one and we cannot do
it without your support so thank you
very much for being here this evening we
are very pleased to have with us author
Juan s Thompson he's here to discuss his
new book stories I tell myself growing
up with Hunter s Thompson in which he
shares the story of his father a
larger-than-life literary figure and
their relationship as they got to know
one another over the course of 41 years
Thompson is in conversation tonight with
best-selling author Douglas Brinkley
whose latest book rifle heritage
Franklin D Roosevelt and the land of
America is on our shelves now ladies and
gentlemen would you please join us in
welcoming Lana Thompson and Douglas
Brinkley we want to welcome one to
Austin he's a long time friend and Robin
Thompson where is Robin is he here right
now where's Robin Robin yeah
Oana has family here in town and these
are hunters kinfolk live here and but
the wanted to begin one's going to do
some reading of stories I tell myself
I'm here because I edited Hunter
Thompson's letters book called the prowl
highway and Fear and Loathing in America
wrote Rolling Stone cover story about
him when he when he died and and you
know I constantly try to well promote
hunter as one of the great American
humorist and great American novelist so
we're going to get to talk about some of
hunter's books but I wanted to begin by
asking you on if you'd like to do a
where maybe just I read a letter you
suggested would you like to you know get
us going with reading something yeah
sure sure thank you
and I would add to your introduction
that you were also a very good friend of
miners for for many years so what I like
to do is read the preface which sums up
what I was trying to do and and what I
was not trying to do and then meet a
couple of letters one letter the hunter
wrote to me and another bit I went to
him when I was going off to college
preface this is a memoir not biography a
highly subjective and unreliable memoir
of how my father and I got to know each
other over 41 years until the suicide in
2005 it is filled with exaggerations
misstatements faulty recollections
obfuscation zou missions it also
contains a lot of truth about my father
in me more truth and falsehoods I think
if I'm deceiving you though
I'm deceiving myself first of all issues
that all I have is memory a memory is a
treacherous thing treacherous as an
unfaithful and perfidious
double-crossing and underhanded memory
is not objective it is not an impartial
recorder but instead a selectively
changeable and unreliable record being
constantly revised and edited to suit
our needs and desires and yet our lives
and our identities are largely built
upon our memories and we trust them
implicitly so you can draw our
conclusions about our lives and the
people in them so we do the best we can
knowing we are fooling ourselves a good
part of the time we go forward in spite
of it I go forward in spite of it these
are the stories I tell myself
Conner's Thompson was a complex man far
too complex for need to know or
understand he was famous almost
worshipped in some circles unknown and
others brilliant a grand master of the
written word and one of the great
writers of the 20th century he was an
alcoholic and a drug fiend a wild angry
passionate sometimes dangerous
charismatic unpredictable irresponsible
idealistic sensitive man with a deep and
powerful sense of justice most important
to me though he was my father and I was
his son and no son can escape the claim
of that relationship good or bad we can
strong alive dead close the distance of
fathers are with us this is the story of
how my father and I went very far away
from each other and over 25 years
managed to find our way back before it
was too late Sonos 18 I spent a week
with on her it was just he and I for the
first time really my life and it's just
just he and I out of Alf arm doing stuff
and it went surprisingly well as I was
getting on the plane in Aspen to fly to
Boston
Hunter gave me a letter he told me to
read it 1000-point september 1st 1982
dear Juan okay you're off and things
seem generally under control on your end
anyway I'm still juggling madness on
this end and I've never even heard a
rumor that the end might be in sight
it's a queer life for sure but at least
it keeps me in shape more or less here
are three valid $50 checks would you
keep you solvent at least long enough
settle in and get a fix on things use
them to open your own bank account in
Boston also call me tonight to confirm
your safe arrival don't forget to do
this tonight the sheepskin jacket is a
present from Laila Boston is cold in the
winter
I'll call dick and Doris Goodwin and
Mike Barnicle the globe to say I'll be
stopping by sometime soon say hello
call your advisor from the Denver
Airport and say they'd be late for
dinner
but to try to make it and you'd like to
meet him tonight asking the best way to
get from the airport to Tufts ASAP and
tell them you're very concerned that
your application for the school
newspaper didn't get there on time can I
help you straighten out the confusion he
can but you have to get serious about it
right away Gaul is a basic tool of
journalism which is a rude business at
best and so much for advice logistics
now I'm not worried about you but I am
interested and I want to know what's
happening
send me your phone number in P Oh
address let's talk on the phone as often
as you feel like it especially for the
first few weeks which will almost
certainly be nervous or maybe not but if
they are don't worry the glum reaper
will be hanging around but to hell with
them we've dealt with a bugger before
and we know the one thing he can handle
is a bedrock sense of humor so remember
the 44 naked and alone books all you
have to do is write the first two I'll
handle it after that and we will both
get obscenely rich take my word for it
why fool around with tangents like all
the others your future is already
assured all you need is a typewriter and
a few reams of paper I'm glad you came
home for a while and I wish it could
have been longer I had a good time and
as always as proud of you very few
seekers go out in the world as well
armed as you are I'll keep after Rueben
$4,000 zero zero technical work
he says he has a fat job for you next
summer but so do I and mine's a lot
fatter 44 books rich and famous by 21 no
problem
anyway I'll figure out C for Christmas
if not before that we had a wonderful
time with Davis and his family last year
and hopefully we can do it again so
let's keep this in mind and plan for it
we saw the ways to go before we can act
like good friends and yell at each other
without worrying about what it all means
but we're doing pretty well considering
the small amount of time it actually put
into it you're a good person and I love
you for that as much as because you're
my son or because you're about to be
rich and pay my expenses forever and
innovating with my wisdom your talent
our bets are covered from the start by
1984 will be making forty four thousand
dollars a month and even Jimmy Buffett
will be standing a line to get your
autograph let's stop looking at this
college expense and start seeing as an
avenue to big money a fine investment
with huge returns in the offing right
yes let's do it
love each sometimes apparently ordinary
events or objects encapsulate vast
realities and this letter is one what is
perhaps most remarkable is that I had
completely forgotten about this letter
until I rediscovered it during my
research for this book it is a letter
I've been waiting for my whole life a
promise of an engaged father who gets
advice gives encouragement promises
adventure affirms the good times and
talks of getting together soon all
sudden I had a father again how could I
forgotten this letter
however we move too fast for a kind of
intimacy that we both wish for but was
not me it could not yet exist I took him
at his word plunged in and sent him a
letter expressing my loneliness sadness
homesickness and depression hunter yes
making the loan in Boston how baffling
this is I'm not like the others the glum
reapers devious this time he hides
outside the window the typical sight
barely visible thankfully he doesn't
show his miserable despairing form but I
know he's there other times he's not so
subtle he and I walked side by side
completely alone so close I can smell
the tears the utter hopelessness of this
endeavor he shows me memories vividness
Tahlia better times its deadly and very
painful and then he retreats I'm
reprieved he never lets me forget he is
there though
devious insidious I feel the best I've
felt since I've been here as I write
this like glimpse off the blade of that
scythe moves a bit further out it's true
I'm not like the others I'm quiet weird
solitary what can we say I'm sure there
are among us five thousand students at
least a hundred people who with whom I
could make friends but there's invisible
as I am the social codes are different
distinctly preppy fraternity sorority
hip flip fasting cute nauseating
artificial I have no doubt that the
majority's people aren't interesting its
likable unintelligent people
unfortunately I've been taught not to
show it the problem lies in socializing
when these people socialize they Don a
common mask they talk a certain way act
a certain way do certain things all of
which have been defined as socially
acceptable by acting in such a way one
makes friends with time friends use
their masks less and less and a true
friendship results
but the mask is so cheap and repulsive I
don't want to use it so I take the
alternative and retreat they can in
quiet and unsociable waiting to meet
someone like me I tried calling you
tonight to answer a play you're right
about that sense of humor the ultimate
weapon unfortunately humor seems so far
away when I most need it I've made a
sign making the loan which I put it on
the wall
perhaps cost us in the place for me and
perhaps the east isn't a place for me
nevertheless I'll definitely plan to
steer year-year to make a fair judgement
when I found this letter to her in the
archive I also found his notes that he
had scrawled on my letter yeah they're
all gay like me
why won't they admit it Jesus what is
sandy rot no College will cure this
problem a handy postpone it for $1,500 a
month and then I would pay the mortgage
and Alla farm I've already paid a $5,000
another 1,000 due October 1st can sandy
take me back to court if I don't pay
so what he'll be in the village by then
a few weeks later under applied with a
rambling and confused letter which you
recounted a story about the last time he
received such a letter in which a friend
of his informed him that he was gay was
going to New York City to deal with his
people honor wrote that their friendship
petered out after if you get together
not because of hon his hostility to gage
that because they now had different
interests in social circles he finished
with this there was a naughty kind of
intensity in her message that was
exceeded only by its obscurity so I
figured I'd just Schaick out in a fog
and see what came of it none of my
doctorates gave me wisdom in areas like
this but I sent something heavier than
just college on your mind and I think I
should know what it is tell me
I had written them two long letters
explaining how lonely and unhappy I was
and his reaction was it tell me I wasn't
being clear and to state the real
problem I'd asked my father who is
previous letter had been so supportive
and welcoming of communication for help
or understanding and malley is of no
help at all
in fact his letter brought up
uncomfortable questions did my father
think I was gay was he trying to say we
would drift apart if we were what was
trying to say did he understand me at
all clearly he could not help me that
first letter from Hunter was beautiful
wishful thinking he wanted to believe we
had that kind of relationship as did I
we wanted to believe we could start over
from that moment and he could be the
father he and I both wanted him to be my
letters to him exploded that illusion
and now I see he had no idea how to
handle this kind of appeal for me he
could give practical advice if I had
asked him for help getting a job getting
a car getting a interview for an article
in the student paper that he could have
handled but a cry of loneliness and a
darkness that he could not handle
one how did things end up working out a
tough after all that one year and then I
came back to the connect the West when I
where I belong and you live in Denver
nesquik um well we thought we'd start by
the word gonzo I mean because every it's
now ubiquitous everybody talks about
gonzo this and gods O'Bannon and hunters
being the person that really made that
word popular in counts of journalism
what does it mean to you gonzo and what
do you think hunter means by it
I think if gonzo journalism what I what
I what I don't think of what what I
prefer not to think of is the is the the
caricature you know of the the crazy man
drinking too much too many drugs out of
control I think what he what he meant
was an approach and an approach to
journalism where he was trying to to get
at an essential truth in an
unconventional way you know through
through exaggeration through you know
these you know humor and he's very
engaging stories as well as you know
some of the rage and the hyperbole but
what he was trying to do he wasn't
writing for entertainment I mean
ultimately he was dee dee he was trying
to make a point and I think that's what
I think that's kind of a nut of it is
there a piece of gonzo journalism or
Hunters Gonzo's style that you would
recommend people read or that you still
find humorous and insightful ah the
addict I mean one is
his his obituary on Nixon which if you
haven't read it is is messing well win
sex it's included in that book of
hungers and it's on the internet' and he
has published in the Atlantic I think
and it's just a scaling vicious
wonderful piece of writing
I don't know if I've ever told you this
about it
so hunter started writing that in New
Orleans he had came down and visited me
and I was at the University of New
Orleans young history professor and
Steven Ambrose who had written three
volume biography of Nixon was there and
so we I thought what a mazing thing to
get Ambrose and Thompson together talk
Nixon took a penis evoke I I had to
introduce hunter at the University of
New Orleans he spoke and then he was
hanging around for like four days and
then Nixon suddenly died and Hunter felt
a lot of pressure writing that he went
back to HL Mencken had written an
obituary of William Jennings Bryan and
and he just justice excoriated Bryan
Macon and Hunter felt the pressure of
that you know I've gone after Nixon all
of these times but he also felt kind of
sad because he lost his enemy because
there have an odd feeling it wasn't
justice like god we always knew who the
crook was the guy I could punch the guy
and now my foil is sort of disappeared
like he was going around a bar on a
little like bull boy bar saying to
people Nixon dog do you want some acid
he's we gotta celebrate X and I you know
and and then but he truly had a lot of
pressure
writing down and he delivered you know
it's not easy it's a piece that I think
circulates a lot this may be the most
funny and humorous and insightful
obituary of somebody you don't like
including dumping his body into a canal
under very epic Elm you should all read
that's a very very funny of a vicious
piece of writing what
about liberty well let's let me just ask
you about Kentucky Hunter is from from
Louisville Kentucky what's his
connection of that city and what did it
mean to Hunter to be a Kentuckian he now
is just in Louisville couple weeks ago
and the city is really starting to
embrace him as one of their you know
they're they're their City heroes but I
don't think I don't think I felt the
same way I think he was I think it was
glad to leave it was an active very
conservative very you know I think they
oppressive and environment where he was
just not welcome he was thrown out of
town and I think he appreciated the
recognition he got back in mid 90s when
a fellow organized a a tribute for
promoting but I don't think he I don't
think he felt a longing for a home I
mean he left he left Kentucky and he
went to you know New York California
ended up in in Colorado because he
wanted he wanted freedom he wanted to be
free of those social constraints and
mores I I don't think he felt a real
tight if Kentucky
I remember when Wanda at it we had an
event with Johnny Depp in Warren Zevon
and David Amram and many others too
which was hunter coming back home and
they gave him the key to the city and he
couldn't believe it because people are
saying no you should never give hunter a
key to anything next city but Harvey
Salone who had been mayor of Louisville
was a friend of friend of hunters we
could get were end up writing about
great piece on about that about
Louisville which is the Kentucky Derby
is decadent into prey and a you know
what would what about hunter and the
Derby or what would you think about that
piece um
it's rollin hunters literary work I
think that's I think that's you know
when you what I think about how is
writing there's this I think it's most
underappreciated book as Hells Angels
which was written you know I was a pre
gonzo and it's a extremely well written
book but it's definitely a much more
conventional style of writing and then
there's and then there's the Derby
article and it was the for and after you
know and I think what happened there is
he he discovered his voice that there
was this this this raw did this rawness
you know this raw power that he didn't
know he had and and they liked I from
what I understand it was you know sort
of in a desperation and he has poured it
out and I think he realized wow this is
something this is something totally new
and and decided to you know instead of
rejecting it as a you know weird
aberration said no there's something
here I'm going to go with this and it is
a sporting event the Kentucky Derby
obviously and Hunter wrote well on the
Superbowl Fear and Loathing in the
Superbowl and went in cursive low note
of cover you know the fitness craze of
jogging and marathon running that was
going on but he constantly cared about
sports and want to be a sportswear to
win any refluxing my when did hunter you
know in hunter and sports in general oh
well I as you say I need love sports I
mean well some sports gave a basketball
football
spies baseball but that was that was a
big part of his life and he growing up
it was you know being a sportsman being
an athlete was always really important
to him and the betting you know
constantly vetting off off at large
irresponsibly large sums of money but
it's interesting a reading about those
early letters when you know you see it's
like wow I'm going to be a sports writer
and then those later letters uh some of
those she remembered by they're an idea
without the when he's just really
killing the the style of sports writing
you know is just this repetitive
formulaic stuff it used to be a
Grantland rice the great sports writer
that hunter kind of worshipped as a boy
and also growing up in Louisville was
the Virginia and tell us about Virginia
Thompson Hunter's mother and what was
Virginia like what did she do how did
she raise the Thompson boys as David be
careful here hop so so on his dad died
when he was about seventeen and he'd
grown up in a really middle-class you
know middle-class family his dad was an
insurance agent his mom was a
stay-at-home mom two younger brothers
and then his dad died suddenly and his
whole world changed his mom had to go
back to work she began drinking rather
heavily for some years and that was a
that was a very difficult for honor
and he ended up and you know condemned
and he was as a result of a arrest and
being thrown under the bus by some well
dear friends he was you know driven out
of town and I think he had his mom was
always very proud of him and she was
tough and she was a survivor she became
a librarian and you know in this Goddard
a murder promoter his mother and his
mother's the librarian so I think books
were around him most him a lot and in
many ways he owes her a lot for for you
know to always be kind of he was being
she would babysit him sitting in the
reading room of the public library
Connaughton in Louisville now years on
the cover of stories I tell myself there
is your dad with the cigarette and the
glasses and there's one as a little boy
what would these would be I mean did you
mentioned alcohol and drugs he did have
an adverse effect on you did it it make
you not care tell us about what living
with somebody who was a kind of a proud
dope fiend in some ways what was that
like you know as a as a kid even now
it's really hard to sort out what was
what was just hunter and how much did
drugs and alcohol have to do with it and
then even now I'm not sure I could say
what I do know is that honor was a
really difficult person to live with and
I did not I didn't want to be like him
you know especially there was some
really tough times I was a 11 12 13 when
my parents weren't divorce and it was he
was he was a he was a he was a bastard
and I really did not want to be like him
you know the craziness the
unpredictability the rage that was uh
how was really difficult
the indeed make you less inclined to do
drugs as the child of somebody's they
were saw the downside of it yeah yeah
well I had it seems that a part of my
character was he'd liked to to see how
far I could go without totally losing
control and I totally rejected that no I
I do not want to be that kind of person
I don't want to have a life of chaos and
and so you know where he was smoking and
drinking by the time it was like 14 or
15 you know I was I was a not quite
straight edge but you know you know
control control you know drink a little
bit but not too much drugs you know it's
kind of funny actually got like through
my drug experimentation point by myself
I was like 17 is like okay I've done
that alright I can move on now we have
instinctive now in the book you have a
lot of wonderful vignettes of well-known
people that hunter interacted with so
I'll just throw a couple of these names
at you and see right here your your
recollections of them let's start with
Jimmy Buffett you mentioned him earlier
there what's what's Buffett's friendship
with hunter like and what was your
relationship with the puppet like I
don't know exactly how they met but they
became friends really before PUF it
became you know really popular
one night he just just released an album
and using I go sailing the Caribbean for
for Thomas for a month or so and I think
harmless I either Jimmy asked my dad
said you know what wanting to take one
with you I was 13 at the time and so you
know I learned all right you're going
sailing with will you know but Buffett
for four per month and okay you know and
I've been listening to Bubba's music for
you know a year anyway
ah and it was a wonderful thing it was
he was so laid-back he was so different
from honor in so many ways that to be
with with someone who was calm yeah he's
calm and friendly and attentive he
really you know you you sort of a
surrogate father figure there for a
while and it was really important too
that way later you know realized that
that's something that he and honored
worked out and Hunter wanted me to have
that break especially because I was
there going to the divorce
it was very severely currently lived in
Key West there for a while and I buff it
was just playing at little outdoor bars
and all in Hunter you know you kind of
like to think he recognized helped
discover him which he did with people
like boss gags and others which brings
me to Hunter music Rolling Stone what
was Hunter's relationship with yon
winter the founder of Rolling Stone
still owns Rolling Stone magazine and
when you know yon quite well what was
their relationship like I'd say two two
opposing things one is a really a deep
and abiding love
I mean I really really think cared very
much for each other and another part of
that was a I don't know who said it but
they said about me on an honor
it was the world's worst employee
working for the world's worst boss it
was I think an extremely difficult
relationship because honor was not he
was not going to be he was not going to
be an employee's wasn't was going to do
it but I think it was very fruitful and
when I think about you know Hunter's
success he was really I think very
fortunate to come that he and yon met up
at that time because there was actually
an opening for for someone for you know
a wolf this wild style of writing which
I don't think I don't know if there's an
opening for that now and getting such a
you know Broadway but rolling stone was
a magazine and they said Neil were yeah
we're ready for this
and I think it turned out to be a great
partnership for them both do you ever
think right now god I wish dad was
around write about Donald Trump oh
that's right yeah I don't know if he
could have handled it but I think we've
been just enraged and appalled by by by
by the whole the whole is a whole
election process what about Johnny Depp
what was hunters relationship like with
him and your take on it so Johnny when
they decided to use Kasper and Loathing
in Las Vegas
Johnny decided to basically live with
honor for four months he's lived in the
basement and he became hunters double
and they went everywhere together and
you know honored to be a deaf Johnny
shaved his head and he was like a
doppelganger and he's got a lot of fun
and
Jonnie Jonnie really respected on her a
lot and I think he kind of looked at
Hunter as a as a kind of a kind of
father figure you know and and 100 died
I think it came through you you know
that
jeonyul on you know you know conveyed
especially what can I do what can I do
and he ended up paying for the entire
funeral which was which was a lot of
money and quite spectacular
I think honor would have been extremely
pleased with how it came out
and what was so remarkable about it is
that he didn't want any credit he didn't
want he wanted to be in the background
this was about I this was not about him
and I'm just so impressed by that you
know that that's sincerity in that
generosity do you think depth caulked
hunter's characteristics and minerals
very well I just I saw it or part of it
I couldn't watch the whole thing a
couple weeks ago and I could close my
eyes and the voice the mannerisms
painter nation God he just nailed it his
yeah creepy no Bill Murray Bill Murray
played hunter in a movie do you have any
reckless no Murray it'll sort of a lot I
was a lot younger than his friend Graham
is this odd odd fellow you know it's a
damn it haha
but but he was strange but but he was he
was he was you know friend he was very
friendly and like
he didn't seem like he had time for me
you know say we you know you're gonna
interesting you know
let's talk where's you know some other
people might have been to kid out on
that time for that yeah he was a system
I don't know how to describe it just a
really interesting unusual person
let's see well what about Jack Nicholson
who never played hunter but they were
they were quite a duo for you know the
great friends
you remember net jacket all I only met
him a couple times but yeah and
underwear were quite close for a girl
for a long time because Jack spent a lot
of time in Aspen I remember when after
Hunter committed suicide at the funeral
Nichols that he did drawings of Hunter
for people that he actually drew and
then signed it for them it's an idol or
DCF dad um did lost the last one of the
person what about Ralph Steadman de
illustrator who teamed up with in Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas most famously
but also cursive lono and other other
projects what's Ralph like Ralph I mean
I think Ralph
I must have first met him when he came
to visit Hunter must been many early 70s
likes probably right after three melding
Las Vegas and he was the most delightful
and kind and really brilliant I mean as
an artist he's just incredible but but
what I'm still in touch with him in his
just came out Ralph is he's such a big
heart he's such a
he is in spite of you know he's 80 years
old now no you know long and interesting
life but he still has just this like
childlike sense of generosity of heart I
think he's a kind of like he neon and it
had a very a very bumpy friendship a
deep respect but also this constant like
bickering and I don't know what what
that was about it was a jealousy or what
it was but - I had that that with a lot
of people it was I think sometimes
because wealth drew him as a cartoon
character and then you didn't like being
a cartoon character at constant course -
Gary Trudeau and the Doonesbury comedy a
couple hundred I know did you ever hear
anything what you ever feel about one
hundred Doonesbury the comic so just he
just he just hated hated anyone of you
know tried to sue me want to find out
where his getting information and it was
creepy because you know I mean they use
my name they use you know sandy his
wife's name you know so that's almost
feeding information at Valley I used I
think what was the worst part of his eye
he was powerless to anything about it
you know yeah um well before we open up
the questions of the audience we
mentioned the Nixon obituaries Kentucky
Derby is decadent depraved as essays and
you rightfully pointed out Hells Angels
as being a classic book of journalism
and now history's in the Modern Library
Edition now meaning it's considered an
American classic Hells Angels and it
will be its 50th anniversary next year
2017 and then he did Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas and then fear and loathing
in the campaign trail 72 now those three
books are considered classics now are
you
when did you become aware that your dad
was you know writing classic books that
were you know not just books of the
moment or Rolling Stone pieces but works
that would be you know being celebrated
in read this many decades later
kind of a slow revelation and very much
I mean as part of doing these readings
well I think first of all when I went at
Hunter's death would be the outpouring
of you know sympathy and and the fact
that so many people talked about how how
Hunter changed their it changed their
lives in some way and that it wasn't his
you know wasn't the craziness and the
drugs and the alcohol that that was that
that touch people it was it was it was
just writing and as I've been doing
these these readings I hear the same
thing and what's just so amazing is how
it is how he continues to be inspiring
to to you know to to not only his
generation or you know my Duran
generation but you know generator but
the next generation thing his influence
continues to to pass down and it's a
it's a wonderful thing to see you know
that he's not just a it was just a
period writer in finally you have a son
will um and he's getting ready to go to
st. John's and Santa Fe the great books
program their incredible program in
school did you learn thing went what's
that like you being a father now is they
giving you a little bit more sympathy
for hunter in the sense of the
difficulties of being a good father yes
yes and the
to see that the difficulty that I had
and trying to connect with women with
Hunter and as trying to find some way to
to communicate or connect is something
you know I can see the same the same
kind of issue with my son and he and I
are more alike than hunter and I but
it's still I think this must be
something that all fathers and sons deal
with it's one pointed as I heart once
you move beyond being a parent and
you're focused on you know child care
you know feeding in the school in the
bedtime and homework or all that stuff
and now it's just two people it's two
people you you are you are tied by this
tremendous amount of experience and you
know so much in common and yet you're
very different people and it has been
helpful to think all right this is this
might just be a part of being a part of
being a father you know and not
something that was unique to just honor
and I good I'd like to open it up for
some questions from the audience
matter we've got some and I won't forget
you guys back there but let's start a
serve right here in the front row mine
can germane to your last comment sir
there was a sportscaster that talked
about Monica Seles when she came back
from her stabbing and he said about her
that she she only can give what she has
to get and that's a quote that's always
resonated about me with my father and so
I wondered does that resonate at all
with you about your father that he can
only give what he needs and that's
something that sort of sort of something
that resonates with me about my father
he could only give what he actually
needed in cell
let's see question okay one you get the
gist now it's not
I'm not feeling a you know it's not
resonating but what comes to mind though
is that he was on I was doing he was
really trying to connect with me now he
was born in in 1936 and he was a very
different being being a man and a father
was something very different then to
what it is now so there was no
expectation that is gonna be a hands-on
dad but but it was very important to him
you know through all that stuff he
wanted to make a connection with me and
I wanted to connect with him and two
thoughts one is that it was it was very
important that we each kept trying even
though we were like you know you know
kept like missing ah and and that would
it eventually came down to for me was
what I realized it's not going to be the
way I would like it to be and so we
found another way and that was and that
was and that was good
but it was really important to say
alright he's not going to he's not going
to be the new-age dad you know
and it doesn't have to be and we found a
connection a different kind of
connection the questions yes sir
like really talking about shams and
played over Socrates will the rest of
your life be only to your virtual father
card old nut
are you aware the gonzo blog blog that's
published every day in England now
dedicated to your father no so it's an
eclectic blog that deals with all
disparate art forms and dedicated to the
app as done by your father I like to
check that out he's very popular in
Great Britain your honor very very major
American writer beloved there yes
there's some back there in the way back
well where they're taping this so if you
could speak into it so if you were to
say so in a sentence or so what you
believed was your father's mantra his
personal philosophy I mean is it a Kenda
gonzo the idea of gotten being gonzo or
is it something separate God mantra jeez
I think when the going gets weird the
weird turn bro I always like that as I'm
actually kind of like a ton of them but
I don't know that I could boil it down
to one
these weren't his words but I would say
tell the truth was a very important very
important to him but but to do it in his
in a in
find his own way to do that you know in
his own his own unique way not trying to
not trying to follow in else's recipe
okay yes sir
one could you tell us a couple of
authors that you particularly like yeah
someone was it just come up with how my
head Jim Harrison who just died a couple
months ago it's just fantastic and I was
an English major so you know some of the
some of the classics and Joseph Conrad
George Orwell George Eliot and he tend
to be put a little probably a little
more classical in my case then you know
avant-garde but those are the view good
well first of all I noticed that you
spoke in my quiet 12 year old voice when
you were attempting to mediate between
hunter and Sandy so my question is to
you and your father signed his letter H
what did you call your parents and did
you inherit the quiet gentle voice from
your mother sandy for the better as a
result of watching them have their
arguments I called them I come on sandy
and yet that's been a lot of people
asked about that and and why you know
and I really think it was that's what
they that's what I'd say it was honor
that's what that's what he wanted to be
called you know how when you're a parent
you know in talking to your child and
you know it's you know it's it's daddy
um you're the one who tells them what
their name is and I think I think Connor
decided notes got a ballute it's got to
be honor it's not going to be dead
and I think part of that was it is
partially him and partially the times
that he was you know the late 60s the
60s and 70s were a time of at least for
the counterculture that he was part of
rejecting like everything everything
that their parents believed in and had
raised them to believe go that you know
everything and that very much applied to
parenting as well and it just who like
when I was in my twenties I think I
tried calling him dad once I'm like oh
and I didn't it doesn't feel right that
could be all right
yes ma'am over here so I'm interested in
the writing of the book were there any
surprises about your dad and were there
any surprises in yourself some of the
surprising things were some of the
letters that I've found there's like a
letter I read and I can't believe that I
just forgotten about the letter quite a
letter and there are other letters I
found where he talks about how he's
going to try to pay for my college
tuition but he didn't want me to know
about it he didn't want me to know that
that about the you know the stress he
was under and that was really surprising
and touching you know so she's got a
character they go you know if there's
not happy by guy here except you know
everybody you know it
surprise for myself I'd say one of the
surprises has been that writing is
actually something that I want to
continue to do it has been a difficult
thing to acknowledge because who wants
to compete I mean who wants to be to be
judged you know compared to you know a
parent in the same area so it's been
it's been a something like a void it's
like that I don't really want to do that
but it turns out you know what I
actually do good yeah you know do a
couple more I'm sorry they're all kind
of scattered around but go ahead over
there if we could my father was a
bastard and an alcoholic your father was
and then having and no point in having a
bastard alcoholic father
it sounds that intimate moments were
rare and thus more impactful and I was
curious if you had one particular moment
as a child in which he relates something
to you perhaps as alcoholics call it a
moment of clarity that resonates
particularly formed you it was palpable
you think uh what you say just ring so
true that I think like unlike my
relationship with my son worried I'm
really as I've been there though the
whole time and so they're just thousands
of you know individual moments with my
dad there there it is aren't that penny
I mean is I don't know dozens you know
and that's what our relationships are
built on and I really realized that
right in the book it's not like I've got
this vast trove of memories of drawn it
like there actually weren't that many
and so you're right they were very
significant what I craved for a long
time and and never did get was one of
those you know meaningful father-to-son
sit-down discussion thread Zico you know
son okay let me let me tell you what you
need to know you know had I never ever
and when I finally just accepted okay
this is not going to happen and so if
I'm going to be to have the connection
that I want with my father it's going to
come from just spending time with them
even if we talk about Gayle politics or
you know whatever it's the it's the it's
the time spent together that mattered
and you know what when you ask that
question the time that comes to mind is
I want to see him in January after
Christmas just before he killed himself
couple weeks and it was a rare thing for
no one to be there it was just he and I
and we ended up watching The Big Sleep
my name's have been a big Bogart and
it's a fantastic movie and it was just
sharing that time together and
appreciating you know a lot of the
aspects of that movie it was it was that
that was a very meaningful time and yet
someone looking at from the outside
would say well you just watch him live
with your dad what's the big deal do you
know what I mean
all right good all right we'll do one
last question if we have any yes sir
if this strange that might be based on
what you told us about him tonight did
he ever try to impart any any words of
wisdom on parenting news or four in his
statement he don't no he did not
and I think he wisely kept his mouth
shut that bet he had that there was he
so let me draw my own conclusions and he
was not going to talk about something
which he did not I don't think he felt
he was really
good at you know something that good he
did not feel that he had done a good job
or he feared he had not to have done a
good job and he I think he was relieved
that I didn't turn out to be a you know
a criminal or a drug addict
well I wanted to tell you one it's been
wonderful having you here in Austin
stories I tell myself makes a great
Father's Day gift and also thank you you
appreciate you you're opening up your
heart and sharing these stories and the
kind of candor that you that you bring
to it and and it's been a wonderful
experience doing this with you and thank
you thank you so one now look you have
other questions he's going to be doing a
book signing so come on and get a copy
and thank you book people for hosting us
yes I am